[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday the 2020 census is set to end
in just 11 days
with the count already affected by the
pandemic the deadline was moved up by
the trump administration a controversial
decision
that is now being challenged but for now
officials in montana the big sky state
are trying to get it done with a big
reward on their minds
major garrett reports
[Applause]
big sky it's the state's name and a way
of living to be in montana is to behold
sweeping vistas and seemingly endless
horizons
but there are practical angles too like
power in washington
montana has one member of congress for
its 147 thousand
square miles montana believes it has
enough population for a second house
seat something it hasn't had since 1993
but first
it has to prove it through a successful
census of its roughly one million or so
population
library open monday through friday from
eight so on radio
do your civic duty and be counted
at libraries and on bulletin boards the
message is as constant as the prairie
wind
be counted that is more challenging than
it sounds
take simple delivery by mail of a census
form
oftentimes they don't have traditional
mailing addresses
and as a result they have not received
the notifications from the census and so
we have about a quarter of the state
that has been you know not getting the
information
mike cooney montana's lieutenant
governor said after labor day montana's
census response
rate is 59 percent montana gets about
two billion dollars a year from the
federal government based on the census
when we do not count a montanan who
should be counted that equals about
twenty thousand dollars over the 10-year
period of the census
things were moving along pretty well
then coveted hit all of the events that
the state was planning to promote the
census had to be canceled
most of montana as you might well
imagine is rural
many residents receive their mail at a
post office box
the census bureau only sends forms to
addresses
if the letter carrier does not match
every post office box
to the corresponding address census
forms go
undelivered amid the pandemic millions
of americans have filled out the census
online
taking pressure off the postal service
montana has a problem with that too
only 59 percent has broadband internet
when you have a system for the first
time where we're asking people
to go on the computer and self-report
and
you don't have the ability to do that
then you have to make adjustments very
quickly and that's why we've engaged
libraries throughout the state where
they do have connectivity
they're just curious they're just like
little kids
lynette o'connor said connectivity
proved a bigger challenge than the
standard
ten census questions probably longer to
to get into the internet then to fill it
out
the state has outfitted its 119
libraries with high-speed internet
a real break for 88-year-old ralph tenby
mainly they just fill out the census i
don't use a computer all that much
and it's easier to have somebody else
help me
click the mail we're going to have to go
in fallon county where census response
is
30 percent librarian stacy moore is a be
counted volunteer scroll down and go to
next
and she's got her work cut out for her
now if you click up here on this top
right there yep
moore was tenbee's census mentor
this should only have taken this five
minutes for cbs this morning saturday
i'm major garrett